il ya un an quasiment jour pour jour je
passais la frontière de l'iran vers la
turquie juste au nord de la syrie sur ma
droite s'élève lémance silhouette du
monde arabe la légende raconte large de
nous et s'il serait échouée 5167 m un
coude comme ça pour un pilote de
parapente comme moi c'est comme une
glace à la vanille un après midi d'été
je me demande trois jours j'ai très peu
de temps sur internet mais j'arrive à
collecter 2 info e1 les conditions sont
magiques pour voler mais par contre il
faut éviter à tout prix les guides qui
risque de me demander mon permis d'accès
impossible à obtenir en si peu de temps
au deuxième matin de l'ascension à mi
pente je suis en train de dormir enroulé
dans mon aile de parapente l'aube n'est
pas encore tout à fait lever comme
soudan
plus tôt c'est le coeur moi c'était
justement là je peux vous dire que je
fonce directe me planquer dans les
rochers sept ans plus tôt le 11 juillet
2008 à 9h30 du matin
je donne le premier coup de pour
un tour du monde avec un vieux rêve
d'enfance alors tous ceux qui dans cette
salle ici penser que le monde est petit
croyez moi c'est complètement faux il
est immense je me donne donc cette fois
ci quatre ans je sais ça va avoir des
conséquences importantes dans ma vie
j'avais un bon travail ingénieurs en cdi
dans l'aéronautique en quelque sorte ce
suicide et ma carrière j'avais une
compagne que j'aimais ma famille mes
amis j'ai tout larguer alors ça sonne
comme une autre belle connerie bien ni
responsable du genre de celle que je
viens de vous raconter sur le mont
ararat
mais en fait c'était sans doute et je le
pense encore aujourd'hui la décision la
plus responsable de ma vie en faisant ça
ce que je cherchais au fond au-delà dans
le monde
c'était de reprendre en main ma vie je
me laisser un peu aller je suis un
schéma classique guider - par des choix
personnel que par des choix presque
imposée par la société et tu carrière
fort matériel moi j'ai tout ça je
n'avais pas l'impression que moi ces
choix étaient vraiment les biens alors
pour une fois j'ai osé prendre une
décision qui allait influer énormément
sur ma vie mais du coup il était
primordial que ce choix là soient
vraiment responsables que j'en mesure
pleinement les conséquences sur la vie
d'abord puis à force de réflexion sans
est venu aux autres aux impacts
environnementaux
à tel point que j'ai décidé que mon tour
du monde serait intégralement non
motorisés zéro carbone pour avancer je
traverserai les continents en vélo les
océans envoie les stops et pour rajouter
un petit peu de magie à tout ça je
prendrai avec moi un parapente pour voir
le monde d'en haut ça a donné le projet
en route avec l as i elle veut alors je
n'ai pas choisi la voie la plus simple
pour me donner une chance de réussir il
fallait donc l'organiser proprement ben
oui je reste ingénieurs malgré tout ce
que je voulais quitter et du coup je le
prends dans un vrai projet d'entreprise
pendant six mois je contacte médias
sponsors
j'étudie le budget le matos qu'il faut
prendre bref j'en fais un vrai business
plan mogador les tableaux excel je me
suis fait plaisir croyez moi et puis
j'ai pris en compte les visas les hivers
dans les andes dans l'himalaya les zones
de guerre pour tracer ceci l'itinéraire
idéal
je savais que si je me trompe et
j'allais en subir les conséquences
un truc tout con par exemple un jour je
traversais le pamir en asie centrale et
je croise en face de moi un cycliste
tout aussi chevelure hirsute que moi et
je peux vous dire que c'était quelque
chose à l'époque
du coup on cause un peu et puis il me
raconte que lui aussi veut traverser les
océans voilier stop et se rendre ainsi
en amérique depuis l'asie comme ça
ailleurs
ça m'a fait une boule au ventre
j'ai dû me résoudre à lui dire qu'en
fait c'était pas possible les voiliers
suivent en effet les alizés et font le
tour du monde vers l'ouest très rarement
la verse et du coup il va se retrouver
en face de l'océan contraintes dans
l'avion alors qu'ils se démènent mais
comme un fou pour rendre son voyage des
motorisés et moi aussi j'ai failli aller
vers l'est mais heureusement un ami est
venu me voir
peu de temps avant le départ il m'a
donné cette information cruciale et j'ai
pu aller non bon sens et c'était
exactement le même genre d'erreur café
le cycliste quand j'étais planqué sur le
mont ararat derrière les rochers à me
faire tirer dessus par des f 16
après la ferme et explosion j'ai cru que
c'était un exercice militaire
j'ai continué jusqu'au sommet du g
décoller le lendemain pour éviter en
volant la zone de tirs de la veille
j'ai atterri sain et sauf et récupère
mon vélo et atteint la première ville où
je rencontre enfin quelqu'un qui parle
anglais
là il m'explique que la montagne est
fermé depuis trois mois qu'elle est
rempli de rebelles du pkk et que l'armée
tire à vue sur tout ce qui bouge
j'ai mis ma vie gravement en danger par
ignorance
pour peu que je mettais un petit peu
informés j'aurais jamais fait ses choix
complètement irresponsable parce que le
manque d'information conduit à des choix
irresponsable et même parfois des
désastres mais à linverse le fait
d'avoir en majorité fait des choix
éclairés responsable où j'étais
conscient des conséquences à terme y de
faire de mon rêve une réalité est même
allé bien au delà quatre mois après le
29 décembre 2015
je franchis la ligne d'arrivée après
2723 jour soit 7 ans et demi sur les
routes au lieu des quatre prévus j'ai
traversé sans 5000 km dans des régions
incroyable j'ai rencontré des gens de
tous les horizons
j'ai eu la chance de voir des merveilles
j'étais heureux et j'ai réussi mon pari
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé pour
moi mais qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
c'était comme ça aussi pour chacun
d'entre nous
et qu'est-ce qui se passerait si c'était
comme ça aussi au niveau plus large de
pays de la planète
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas de penser à
une société plus consciente donc plus
responsable et donc plus libres parce
que un tour du monde
un projet de vie en société c'est comme
un vol en parapente
c'est un truc qui pourrit contraintes de
risques mais qu'on a choisi nous mêmes
et dont on fait tout pour contrôler les
conséquences
j'ai mauvaise lecture du vent c'est la
mort ou la paralysie
mais l'envol c'est ce moment ultime
cet instant de vérité où les choix
deviennent vraiment responsable et nous
emmène dans une immense liberté
alors on s'envole